here come here come to scovilles hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Charlie Day you know
miss Charlie Kelly on FX as It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia and you can catch
him starting alongside Ice Cube in his
new film fistfight in theaters February
17th charlie welcome to the show thanks
man
thanks I'm already a little disappointed
myself I'm shamelessly promoting a movie
right and then I'm gonna hurt myself to
do it
and I don't think I don't think there's
any correlation between people watching
me eat hot sauce and and going to see
the movie but let's hope how are you
with hot food I'm okay with I mean I
like it yeah I don't you know I'm not
crazy but you're not death sauce crazy
no you ready to get it going charlie
yeah let's stop [ __ ] around let's get
into this
[Music]
all right so this one's sriracha
sriracha is no big deal uh-huh
[Music]
but look I don't want to start with
fistfight because you're playing
alongside one of our favorite people and
Tracy Morgan who of all the working
actors it seems to me is one of the few
who have the behind-the-scenes antics
that are sometimes more entertaining and
outrageous than the shows that he's in
oh yeah movies that he said yes I don't
know if he realizes that he's in the
movie industry or if you know that's
just happening and people are pointing
cameras at it and he'll tell you the
same joke about five hundred times he
come up to me be like you tried it like
you know what this is slapping his
belly's like a mating call and the first
time you see it you know he's sort of
like hi man that's funny
and then he does it like 500 times yeah
that's a thing it like goes through a
hole where it's like kind of funny and
then gets kind of annoying
yeah then longer sudden is the funniest
thing ever me are you okay and then oh
you're genius what do you think we're
surprised people about him probably that
he's a white guy and that's all black
really yeah yeah yeah no it's in
terrible taste
[ __ ] you Tabasco Bueller what don't you
like about it
nuts not salty enough we should be
concerned about your levels of salt I
know like I'm afraid to go to a doctor
because I feel bad man I got about a
couple more seasons of this I want to
talk to you about Wade Boggs because
furlong is I can remember those flight
drinking stories have been the stuff of
legend like two cases on a flight from
New York to California I've heard him
quoted at a hundred and seven beers when
you did the beats Boggs episode with him
what sorts of details were you able to
draw out of him one hundred and seven
beers comes from me because he he told
me that cuz the story was I think it was
like that he drank 55 beers
cross country flight and then you know
his teammates were coming out there like
no it was more like 80
you know we wrote the episode about it
and then we're shooting the episode he
goes Charlie who's actually 107 now how
anyone remember
murrs that they drank 107 beers is like
how do you how do you remember that
right believe him yeah cuz you was
drinking beer when we were filming the
episode he's got like well those hot
dog-eating stomachs but for beer how you
feeling uh a little ashamed myself and a
little excited and a little confused
what was the worst thing about being
neighbors with Zac Efron heard nothing
bad about the kids never there you know
cuz he's always off doing a movie he
also is like showing me up like he'll
send like a lovely Christmas basket with
little crackers and [ __ ] like orange no
like happy holidays Zac I was gonna ask
like does he borrow lawn care items
do you ever dog sit like how neighborly
does it get but it sounds like he's kind
of new he's a [ __ ] class act this kid
this awesome fine with us the wings that
I'm finding mildly disgusting really
because I was going in my head on eating
these I'm like these wings taste better
than like 9 out of 10 episodes like this
oh really the wings a good stuff you're
getting like our best right now I'm just
realizing don't shake it it's not all
coming to you I'm remembering at all can
you tell this story about meeting your
wife and co-star Mary Elizabeth Ellis is
it true that you and a buddy kind of
called dibs at the same time and you had
to arm wrestle for who got the right to
approach her first yeah I guess one of
my skinniest weakest friends so I was
able to beat him an arm wrestling
competition and starting to feel like
[ __ ] and we arm wrestled and and I won
[Music]
and I met my wife do you ever think
about how your life might be different
if you would have lost that arm
wrestling match no I still would have
talked to her because I'm you know not
the most honorable person right
[Music]
siliceous
Thank You charlie I'm related mm-hmm
my kid threw up today and there's
something that like when your kid throws
up you're like well at what point am I
gonna throw up you think it is probably
soon this kinda it's not gonna help it
isn't I apologize that different than
the other one it's a blueberry one I
want to talk to you about your
commencement speech at Merrimack College
i sat on those uncomfortable chairs I
dressed like some sort of medieval
pastry chef and I do desperately hoped
that my hangover would wear off what I
want to do is give you some commencement
speech cliches oh who can tell me if you
think that they hold up or if they're
just some empty hollow platitude that
people just say okay that sound good
let's do it if you do what you love
you'll never work another day in your
life that's [ __ ]
such [ __ ] right yeah everybody works
except really rich people you know who
are like the sons and daughters of rich
people I assume they don't work maybe
even they work a job is still a job a
dream job is still a job everybody I'm
I'm here eating eating stupid hot sauces
to sell my movie this is this is work
don't be afraid of failure well that's
true and I said that I think you're
trying to catch me I'm not yeah a lot of
people said that well that's true you
can't you can't be afraid of failure
this is the first day of the rest of
your life that's unlike every
commencement speech that's a fast day of
the rest that's a fact that's an easy
fact that they someone's come up with
because it sounds those so big and so
grand like didn't mean something in the
first day of the rest of my life yes
unless you die that day and then it's
the last day of the rest of our life
over the rest your life or just the last
day reliable this one we've got the
ghost pepper and blueberry sauce it
turns the wings blue we had a thousand
and one questions about It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia but we don't have
time for that so what I want to do is
kind of rapid-fire it's always sunny
questions at ya and you just keep it
going does that sound good
yeah what is the official catchphrase of
choice that fans scream at you and the
airport kittens
speaking of kitten mittens and the dick
towel and all these great products that
you guys have in the show have you ever
been approached by some sort of Mark
Cuban like shark who wants to take some
of these ideas to market even if it's
just some sort of novelty item we sold
the dick towels for a little bit
ourselves
did it make money a little bit money we
want to have facts because usually
anything that is sold off the show
they're gonna make the money because
that's how this business corporations
work but they don't wanna sell towels
with big and tiny penises on them yeah
yeah and so we had no problem of that uh
we made a little bit of money and then a
tapered off I think there's a shelf for
like for how many people want to buy
those how much alcohol is actually
consumed on set nothing really I mean
there's been a couple times where
earlier when we're making the show we
were like yeah that's the last day of
shooting let's let's have some drinks
but it's a long day you got a lot of
work to do of all the songs that you've
written for the show which one are you
most proud of
Dave man uh people go nuts okay by the
way it was weird this is where it's
gonna get bad I should have said that
cuz I got the apocalypse and dub on Mad
Dog and then Megadeth which is dumb are
you ready to go into zombie apocalypse
yes
[Music]
season three of eating an odd sauce oh
yeah this is where does glades the
internet seems fascinated by the early
roles that you had before you're in it's
homey sunny in philadelphia whether it's
a Law & Order episode Ressa services
bagels commercial yeah all the good
stuff which do you think was the most
underrated performance there's one that
is not on there it was a good story my
agent at the time called me and said hey
Austin Pendleton is doing this thing and
another guy named Victor Argo who's in a
Scorsese movies is also in it and
there's a part for like a young guy at a
bar that's like three lines you know go
audition so I'd go audition I get the
part
super excited my first name is second
acting job the part is me and my buddy
having some kind of conversation about
sex or something and Victor Argo is
overhearing it and he's depressed
because he doesn't have sex anymore
whatever now I never see it I never find
it shows up on my IMDB as erotic tales
for [ __ ] is this man
it's like softcore porn and it has since
also disappeared off my IMDB I I didn't
put it on and take it off so I don't
know what happened so I think it's my
most underrated performance because no
one has seen it or rated it but out
there somewhere in the world is Charlie
day and I missed I'm in I'm in you know
Simon erotic tales for so
comes on oh there is
you feel it build and then it's kind of
like pops like a balloon it starts like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah it starts like
it's no big deal
what's in these things what makes that
happen very few of our guests read
charlie yeah I'm just pretending to read
what are all the sorbets and them and
the bends at deeds you know these are
questions I should ask that I know a
buddy I am so seriously worried about
you well I was about to thought mm-hmm
like inside my tooth mm-hmm like found
them a week a week source that's what it
does it finds her vulner
It's Always Sunny as one of the motions
geographically referential shows on
cable it is very much a part of the city
of brotherly love
sorry I'm no longer standing myself and
I'm now fairly proud of myself you
should be you shouldn't be this is no
small feat yeah yeah Charlie care about
getting through this hot sauce challenge
what I want to do is get the Charlie Day
guide into Philadelphia so you know some
dilemma it's no reason you want to do
this or do you want to do that does that
sound good
oh yes the Liberty Bell or the
Philadelphia Museum of Art I go to the
Museum of Art cuz the other thing is
just a broken Bell allen iverson her
Eric Lindros I ever said it come on
Paula notes are the roots you know what
I gotta go the roots because I saw Halle
notes recently live and you know left
little bees yeah yeah they're all yeah
the aging their voices aren't as strong
they play bridge the roots still got it
and they didn't [ __ ] play rich girl
man oh so rocky or rocky - or rocky 3 or
rocky 4 or rocky 5 or Rocky Balboa or
Creed
right Rocky
this is mad dog 357 Charlie you're doing
her like a champ
if you okay I feel okay my teeth are hot
my lips yeah are burned we might as well
go for it I'm waiting for it there's
nothing's happening yet I know that's a
lie I feel like you've done it I'm okay
which i think is [ __ ] like the fans
are gonna be super disappointed they
want me be okay let me get through this
easily they want me to be like crying
you're [ __ ] my pants no Charlie
that's all right you don't hold it I
don't know any but no [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're beating them and I'm fine oh it's
not like I spoke too soon here comes
your God here come two scovilles all the
schools are rushing to my veins
Rhode Island here you grow up yeah it's
a place that seems misunderstood by the
rest of the country and since they take
great pride and being misunderstood by
the rest of the country sure and nowhere
is that more evident than in the food so
what I want to do is take some Rhode
Island food staples and if you can just
explain them to me I'd appreciate it
okay yeah what is a New York system
Wiener Rhode Island so funny yeah that I
grew up on an island which is like which
is like at the bottom of Rhode Island
and like what's Providence maybe ten
times in my life which is where you
would get those scope those Scoville I
will send Ellicott see those wieners
you're talking about have you ever heard
of a Quahog I've heard of a Quahog now
is it Klan wrapped in a rubber band
that's out first you stuff it full of
strange breads and then you wrap it up
careful with the eyes yeah good thinking
man and then you wrap it with a rubber
band and then you cook it somehow and
you've been you eat it Oh buddy nuts for
real
it's tradition around here dab the last
wing you don't have to if you don't want
to charlie just a little dab just little
dab nothing crazy
this isn't a time for showmanship we
don't have to Liberace this whole thing
I just want to see what it says about it
scovilles nothing it's the innumerable
amounts I think it's 550,000 but here's
what I would say Charlie I think that
that is expressed too much that's a man
who's going to himself I I don't want to
be like see when I've got to feel any
responsibility for what about those
about to go down
I've done that be real we want to switch
the switch you're gonna do that I would
rather do it than you do it Oh charlie
Oh
[Music]
it's always sunny as a show that divides
convention in every single way just beat
up your questions you have to it's just
out of necessity this do-it-yourself
Giordano pilot becomes one of the
longest-running live-action comedies in
the history of television
I know that you're gonna tell me that
you don't but I have to think that you
think about how it's gonna be remembered
I have to think that you think about its
place in history why in your opinion do
you think it's outlasted all the other
shows of its kind but first and foremost
I'm are you okay but you know what's
weird as I find that I'm a late bloomer
here it comes
mm-hmm I'm like a same thing happen with
puberty as you can tell by my height and
my voice but um yeah [ __ ] you I made a
mistake mm-hmm is there an end in sight
or is it just inevitably until you get
cancelled or it gets canceled
we'll see what we could do man no see if
we can keep going okay there's something
wrong because I kind of secretly like
this you do you want a bottle no do you
ever think about its place in history do
you ever think about it uh no who gives
a [ __ ]
and finally movie ever thought of a
movie I mean it's not much point because
it's like usually when you do a movie of
the show it's so you can do the things
you can't do on the show what Charlie is
[ __ ] hot you made it through you
doused the last wing and death sauce let
the record show Charlie you're a legend
or I'm not a legend of a man who
shamelessly ate a bunch of really hot
sauce to promote his movie this camera
that camera that camera let the people
know what you have going on in my life
if you go see fist fight it's awesome if
you don't I'll be fine
you know I'll be my career be over and I
will beat the Bojan sauce in vain in
vain oh man that's
[Music]
you sure you don't want the death sauce
it actually is like it's like it feels
kind of good you feel it alive
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
like the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you like the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend